ever since Ron mallet was a boy he
harbored a dream of building a time
machine
today he is professor of physics at the
University of Connecticut and is ready
to share his secret with the world it's
really such a powerful feeling to know
that we're actually being able to
manipulate space and time and it's
exciting because this shows that we may
be able to control time and that means
that ultimately we may be able to
control our destiny in a way that
mankind never has been able to before
mallets motivation began when his father
died suddenly of a heart attack just 10
years old at the time and totally
devastated mallet made a pledge if I
could build a time machine
then I could go back and see him again
and maybe save this life for almost half
a century and like many other scientists
he has conducted his research in closed
laboratories it's only been since my own
breakthrough at the end of the 20th
century that I finally allowed myself to
come out of the time-travel closet so to
speak if he is right the 21st century
will see time travel make the leap from
theory to reality
mallets early work was hidden away in
the Time Traveler's code
he studied black holes particularly but
always kept an eye on what was happening
within the time travel of fraternity the
early work of my colleagues that really
inspired me was the work that that had
been done in rotating black holes in
wormholes and in cosmic strings all of
these things lead to the possibility of
time travel into the past what I was
interested in was a mechanism something
that could be used as a device that was
different the common theme that unites
rotating black holes wormholes in cosmic
strings is gravity mallet search to find
a new way to harness gravity in order to
time-travel though light has no mass it
does have energy mallet was convinced
that he had to take an unorthodox step
to build his time machine and I found
that light could be used to control
gravity and since gravity controls time
then that meant that I could use light
to control time and that's the basis of
my inspiration in my theory
mallet guarded his ideas before
announcing his theory he had to make
sure it had substance he wanted to find
a way to replicate the frame dragging of
a black hole in order to twist
space-time around into a loof the answer
was staring him in the face
[Music]
and I thought when if I can create the
circulating beam of light then the
circulating beam of light can lead to a
twisting of space should lead to a
twisting of space and if it does lead to
a twisting of space then it should also
lead to a twisting of time four months
mallet worked on his equations he
checked and double-checked the figures
until he was ready to unveil his ideas
to the world while cosmic strings and
wormholes would require an advanced
super civilization with the power of the
galaxies at their fingertips mallet
claims his time machine could be built
not in the future but today what you're
seeing are four intersecting laser beams
that are forming a square in which the
light is circulating around when the
space is being dragged around by that in
in addition to the twisting of space
eventually in a real model you'll have a
twisting of time as well this is a model
of mallets time machine according to his
theory the laser beams will create
enough gravity to replicate the frame
dragging of a rotating black hole some
claim this theory is off-the-wall but
Mallett insists his machine could create
a tiny time loop
the real size of the real device however
is going to be only about the width of a
human hair and rather than just having
seven lasers like this model they'll be
ten thousand mallet is now ready to step
from model to Time Machine the time
traveller in his miniature machine will
be a subatomic particle think if we
could warn ourselves of future
catastrophes we don't need to send
someone back if we could just send
information back or if we could send
back scientific information medical
information let me think about that
think about if we could send back a cure
for AIDS a cure for cancer
that's more significant than sending
people back the boy who dreamed of
travelling back in time to save his
father's life might be on the verge of
building a time machine but Mallett the
physicist now accepts he'll never be
reunited with his father time travel to
the past would only begin the moment his
time machine is switched on only time
will tell if Mallett's machine is
successful